This is FRESH AIR I'm Terry Gross.
We're closing two thousand and fifteen with a series of some of our favorite interviews of the year. Up
first Larry Wilmore last January he started his program the nightly
show which is on Comedy Central right after the Daily Show. He'd formerly
served as the Daily Show senior black
correspondent the nightly show has become a great place to go for a comedic take
on the day's news and occasionally for some genuine outrage. Wilmore and his
team are especially good at addressing issues dealing with race and that's perhaps the
most difficult subject to talk about in America.
We're going to hear the interview with Will more that was originally broadcast on August
nineteenth the day of the nightly show's hundredth episode we started our interview
with a clip of the show from the previous week when he marked the one year anniversary of the
day eighteen year old Michael Brown was shot to death by white police
officer Derren Wilson in Ferguson Missouri.
This past Sunday marks one year since the shooting death of Michael Brown and subsequent president.
Ferguson The man I can't believe it's been a year already.
I mean it's crazy how time flies are in a constant panic about getting shot by the
cops.
Larry Wilmore Welcome back to FRESH AIR and congratulations on what you've been doing on your
show you choked on the first edition of YOUR show that all the good bad
race stuff had already happened and there was like nothing left to say like you're
done since then I'll just Brattle off a list here.
Walter Scott was killed by a cop and Charleston South Carolina Freddy Gray died in a police van
a cop pulled his gun on a black teenage girl and then sat on her as she was returning from a pool party
in
Texas. Bill and Ruth killed nine people at the Emanuel Ammi church in
Charleston the Confederate flag was removed from the statehouse in South Carolina
Sandra bland was stopped after failing to
signal when she was changing lanes. She she died in jail. Probably a suicide.
You know. Versity Cincinnati campus policeman killed Samuel
Dubose I know you knew that there was going to be racial stuff
happening but really did you expect all this to be happening
early on the
show that is the saddest introduction to a comedy.
And I
think it's just a
typical American sound like the
me you know this is the stuff you have to deal with on your
comedy show and so now find
what's funny about it so that you can
know it's not a lot there's really not a lot.
After the shooting at the. Emanuel Ammi church. In Charleston
South Carolina night nine people were killed there massacre really
horrible and then it's up to you to find something to say about it I want to play
how you handled it so here's Larry Wilmore on the nightly show.
Now I have to tell you guys when we're going to talk much about this that I mean there's a comedy
show all right. I mean what we've built here isn't really designed to handle this kind of
tragedy and let me just say I know we talk about race a lot on this show but I think we can all
agree this time that this is a racially motivated
attack. You know I think
it's but also
it couldn't be clearer when it comes out of the killers now all
right but even with all of that evidence and on a day like today.
Fox News just makes my head explode.
Last night deadly attack taking place in a historic church in South Carolina the gunman's horrifying
attack on
faith the question is Was it a crime out of race or
religion they could be calling it a hate crime because it happened in a religious institution.
So we're not safe in our own churches and where are we
saying there was sleeting investigated as a hate crime. There are still some pieces we have to put together.
Look at it as well it's because it was a white guy apparently and a black
church but you made a great point just a moment ago about the hostility
toward Christians so perhaps and it was a church.
OK
I know you guys don't want to admit that racial stuff is going racial stuff isn't
going on but how can there be any doubt when it came out of the gunman's mouth. Let
me remind you what he said I want to show you black people.
He told his victims. I want to shoot black people I think when he
says black people he means black people and
not
Christian Larry Wilmore on the nightly show did Fox
News make it easier for you to find where the joke was because they became.
The joke in a way.
Yes in that sense. Absolutely. In part of you kind of feels a little
guilty for even having laughs on that day but then the other part of you feels like sometimes you need to
laugh just to express some kind of emotion just to be able to deal with those types of
of tragedies. You know they're trying to do that all the time in America but
there are certain types of tragedies that kind of pull it together and make us pause
and give us a chance to reflect about where we are we're going in that sort of thing
and it's incidents like this that I think give those that type of
opportunity. So you know getting laughs out of it were
a comedy show that's kind of our job. Unfortunately it is the biggest irony of ironies I
think I've ever faced in my entire career Terry I'll be honest with you that I would be mining this type
of territory on a daily basis and getting Lanse out of it.
So I want to give another example of how you've been dealing
with issues in the news so this was after
Sandra bland was pulled over for minor traffic violation and a police
dash cam recall. Or did what happened you played the
video and showed how the police officer keeps escalating things like she's in
a bad mood and his room being like totally compliant about it but he
keeps escalating things in ways you know surrendering
out until he finally like demands that you put out her cigarette that she gets out of the car
he threatens to remove her from the car and I should mention in this clip that we're going to hear
we're also going to hear a clip within the clip of Don Lemon on
C.N.N. I saw a woman who was very irritated probably having a bad day. Most likely because
she was pulled over
right. Smoking a cigarette the comedown comply with everything the officer asked
for then it got confusing because he told her to put out her cigarette. But
then offered to light her up by pointing a Taser at her head that to me a most reasonable
people it's very clear that this officer was wrong.
If you have are being stopped by a police officer was that police officer is right or wrong.
Don't you do what he says until afterwards. Then you can sue him then
you see the law.
OK First of all I don't know who you're yelling
at and secondly should one be on one's
best behavior when the cop pulls one over Ideally yes but most importantly the cop is a
professional.
I mean should he not have been on such a power trip. OK
now I'm yelling Don Lemon
say let me come to him for the good.
I mean it's easy to say but people want you acting like the downward count is when a couple
you over all of a
sudden expectedly drunk doesn't
mean you like to see I'm a good my good component that
is put next to my stash of weed use is actually going to.
I mean yes that would make sense but on the other hand the fact. That we live in a world
where black people have to strategize So they're not brutalized by police is there to
say
OK that last line. That's not even a comedy line
that's just like I know this is insane line yet. Can you talk
about coming up in the writers' room with how you wanted to handle this particular
story right. Well that's our thesis point. That's the line that.
I'll say look here's what I feel is going on here at this moment I had
just really read. Malcolm Gladwell book Blink where he talks about those moments of
escalation that police officers can go through any he uses the incident. I think that happened I think it was
in Harlem. I'm not sure where he carefully plotted it's fascinating Terry of
how each second there was a certain type of escalation that didn't
necessarily need to happen. You
know and how much of it it is that is the officers responsibility
to be in control of that and that's what training is for that's why training is so important in police
work is
to make sure. Your body doesn't take over what you're
supposed to do because your heart starts racing and you just get into this mode a lot of this I don't even know
about you know it's almost like you go into dinosaur brain mode one day just takes
over and you just act instinctively and when you're acting instinctively in this kind
of primal level a lot of things happen things like when we talk about systemic by so those type of
things you act out in certain
ways and it's very worrisome to me something that we don't talk about in police
behavior towards certain individuals. And that's what I was thinking about
when we were doing that piece was Gladwell. Yeah this woman had a bit of an attitude she was
bit upset that day I don't know what was going on to her but I feel like it's still regardless of
that the police officers his responsibility not to escalate that but to escalated
to pointing a Taser at her and drag it out of that car was so
unnecessary and also the fact that as a black person in
America when you're pulled over by the police. You have to
strategize in a way so bad things don't happen to you you know it's
just terrible. Are you feeling that personally.
Well I have an
interesting relationship with this my father was in law enforcement growing up.
He was a probation officer and I've always understood the
point of view of the peace officer. You know because of my dad
and so what's interesting is that because I have that understanding I think I'm a little bit
harder. Because I
feel it's their job to be better than in that situation not to be on our
level you
know and I have buddies back in Pasadena who are on the force you know and we talk. I
understand how difficult their job is and the things they have to face it's very
difficult police. Have to have one of the most difficult jobs in society today. But at
the same
time I think a person in that position their responsibility has to
be high as well.
So
one of your real issues is Bill Cosby you do not miss an
opportunity to go after
Cosby and you exemplify that. We're going to play a piece that you did on
the Voting Rights Act. And campaign on voting restrictions in which you still
manage to drive to drive to Cosby So here's
Larry Wilmore.
Let me just remind us why we have the Voting Rights Act fifty years ago Lyndon Johnson got to say is
definitely one of my thoughts I'm
Linden's past the V.R.A. which prohibited any and all
discriminatory voting policies so no more literacy tests no more poll
tax right so what's changed. Well in this case they're not so much trying to revise
history as they are trying to revive history.
The new rules reduced early voting to ten days from seventeen eliminated same day
registration ended a program to pre-register high school students and
band out of precinct voting.
They're making voting.
Them Bill Cosby at a sleep clinic.
That's right.
I mean the guy in the value of not the value of a
governor three more women came out against you yesterday you sick
bastard All right. I got a Google alert on this.
In fact the only reason I did this whole piece. The only reason I talked about
Gerry and Hillary and the Voting
Rights Act. The only reason why I woke up this morning shall we put my deodorant certain type
been tossed when I was doing my hair the only reason the main reason I'm
here
tonight was so I could just tell that joke and call you out and let me just
say worth it.
Later Well more. So you're hardly alone in being angry at God Yeah
but you seem to have like a special anger and it made me wonder
like do you know him from T.V. circles because he's know you you know you've
written down that call. Wouldn't have surprised me that if you worked with cars be know
if you heard no worries about cars be. Yeah that I have you had you
heard about that in the past.
Yep you know. I think the thing that makes me the most well there
are certain several things about that that make me angry the period of time that
these things have happened over the fact
that these women have these allegations that people could care less
who cares about what women have to say you know you know the whole idea of a powerful man being
able to shut up all these women is so apparent to
me that issue was what really drove me first is the idea that a
powerful man can just shut women up you know that's what started this whole thing.
It had nothing even to do with the fact of liking cars beer not liking concerts was that
simple issue and I don't even know how much of a feminist I was when I realized oh my God I
was raised by single mom.
The six kids have three sisters. Larry you've been a feminist your whole life you really didn't
know it and to have been presented with these issues. It was the kind of the
issue that made me realize how much I really cared about women's issues
and how much I realize it's important for me to be an advocate for issues that aren't
necessarily my own to be an ally for
issues. So if I don't do anything else. Look at the race stuff all that
stuff it's funny even if that went away. I think me being an ally for
women's issues is probably the most important thing that I that I think I'm doing on the
show so your show started in January and Martin Luther King
Day And it's it's changed I think it's really a volatile I liked it a
lot when it started I like where you're going now describe a little bit. How you've
tried to
really you know just like toy with the format of the show as the
show was learning. Whereas you were learning what the show's voice was.
For me personally as a host. Oh man Terry it was so difficult the first couple months.
I mean you're just in the middle of the storm just trying to figure out how to do the show wondering
if it's working if
it's even feel funny and and as I was doing it I got a lot of counsel from
Jon Stewart which was great and Jon was very tough on me about the way. But tough in a good way
where he's tough donjon is always tough with the truth. You
know he gives you praise when you when you get it you know when you're there when
you when you're seeing it. You know he's really he has clarity is really amazing.
It's frustrating because he's he always seems to be right his one of the most frustrating things about working and.
It's true even when you think No Just so you're wrong on this one about a week later you
go oh yeah he's right. How did he do.
Can you give us an example of something he said that turned out to be really good advice. Well absolutely
the biggest thing he said in the beginning he's he and he would almost say it with not
really anger but maybe frustrate. She would see. Hey man.
Stop being a host stop it you know just be yourself just be yourself out
there just hosting the show what does that mean whether that mean to you.
Well it took a while for me to interpret what it is when you're first
starting a show like that your acting everything because you're not comfortable
yet you know but you can't fool John he can see right through that.
So no matter how much praise I got about the showdown thing no no no no no you're you're pretending this
right now you're not owning it yet you've got to own it. You've got to put your opinion out there and you've
got to just get inside there and just be you know we had these conversations
several times you know and he would be more emphatic each time and it was funny because
sometimes he would do this this was hilarious. I would do like what I thought was a really fun show
I thought man that was really fun you know that was funny and so I mean the Johnny goes so Mansell's the
house of God. How did you think last night show it and I know that's a trap. I already know
it's just. I go oh I thought it
was like Oh you
did you did I thought it was
good and then we start the conversation and I fully realize OK I get why
he's considering it now what I should be doing it for him it
didn't matter that I got last or that I got this he was always encouraging me to raise the
bar not just in content but in making sure that my point of
view was very clear and very precise and that I owned it and then I was myself so he kept pushing me
into that so that was the evolution of the show to be honest with you it all centered around that.
So you were describing how Jon Stewart told you you have to develop your voice. You have
to have an opinion on it I want to play an example of a piece where I think he really did that
so this is about the Confederate flag. This is before it was officially
taken down
and in South Carolina so there is still the controversy about whether she should
be taken right on.
So here's your take on that on the nightly show.
OK For the record the Confederate flag is not a proud symbol of tradition or heritage it's a
symbol of oppression and intimidation. That's not my opinion that's an objective
fact on March twenty first eight hundred sixty one the vice president of the
Confederacy Alexander H. Stephen
stated that the Confederate government was based on the great truth that the Negro is not equal to
the white
man that speech is now called but cornerstone speech because that
idea is the cornerstone of the Confederacy.
You don't get clearer than that.
Now some people say that southern states should fly the Confederate flag because it's a symbol of their heritage but if
we flew every flag from our past why aren't we find a Union Jack in front of the White
House
and for the record South Carolina. You don't get to make the heritage argument because the
Stars and Bars has been flying over the state house since the Civil War It went up in one nine hundred sixty
one to mark the centennial of the Civil
War and coincidentally right around when the black people
started with the one thing of the civil
rights and one nine hundred sixty one. It was a
reminder to black people that they should know their place. It has always been used as
a symbol of intimidation and terror and that's what remains today in fact
because displaying the swastika is illegal cross much of Europe skinheads and neo nazis
often adopt the Confederate flag in its place.
It's such a racist symbol that it does double duty as the backup brace of
symbols for
the general.
OK So older the records. I get it there are
plenty of honorable people have fuzzy feelings about the Confederate flag but that's irrelevant.
Where
the styles are will never trump the people who see it as a symbol of hate and for a state to fly this flag
that hey. The matches. They send to their people so for the record doesn't really have to be a
debate on whether or not you should take it down just take it
down you will get in trouble.
Due to break
down
no less Larry Wilmore on the nightly show well you had a point of
view that clearly expressed.
Yes and that and by the way John called me up on those
occasions it's a that's what I'm talking about if you say that after that I. Yes
absolutely he said that's what I'm talking about you know and
I was like yes I understand that you
know my interview with Larry Wilmore was originally broadcast on August nineteenth
of this year the day of the hundredth episode of his Comedy Central program the nightly
show.